termino la segunda fecha de esta copa
américa femenina hoy comenzó la
actividad en el grupo bay con el clásico
suramericano que se disputó en la ciudad
de armenia allí se encuentra nuestra
enviada especial estefanía montero
estefanía goleada convincente de brasil
que revalida de que es efectivamente la
gran favorita
4 goles por 0 fue el resultado final
aquí en el centenario de armenia de
clásico suramericano entre brasil y
argentina en brasil contundente y que
reafirma porque es el favorito y el
reciente campeón de este certamen
adriana da silva la figura de la cancha
quien marcó dos de los cuatro tantos de
brasil una argentina que lo intentó por
momentos del partido pero que realmente
nunca encontró la fórmula para generarle
peligro a las brasileras estefanía antes
tuvimos otro partido victoria por la
mínima de venezuela sobre uruguay
un gol por 0 fue lo único que pudo hacer
venezuela frente a un uruguay que
sorprendió con su planteamiento táctico
realmente las venezolanas lo intentaron
muchas veces pero no encontraron la
fórmula y falló mucho la definición
hablamos con dina castellanos la autora
del único tanto de este partido y le
preguntamos cómo se sintió tras volver a
la selección después de su lesión
contenta la verdad que con mucha ilusión
de estar de vuelta con el equipo poco a
poco estos partidos me van a ayudar a
agarrar más ritmo que creo que eso es lo
que lo que me está faltando ahora un
poco porque como sabemos empecé a
entrenar fue llegando a cada armenia así
que nada lo importante es que las
sensaciones del tobillo están bien y que
no no me duele na
bueno como vimos la delantera de la
selección venezolana va a pedir más
ritmo va a querer jugar mucho más con
esta selección venezolana mañana habrá
jornada de descanso y el lunes se
retomará con los partidos del grupo en
santiago de cali